eso
[Música]
crecer es aprender a mirar el mundo a
través de un conjunto de imágenes que
vamos coleccionando todos los días y
quizás el aprendizaje más difícil es
aprender a mirarnos a nosotras mismas
por eso que nuestras madres abuelas y
otras mujeres en nuestro entorno son tan
importantes ellas son mujeres espejo en
ellas nos reflejamos y vemos ciertos
rasgos nuestros pero también podemos
descifrar e indagar cómo nos ve la
sociedad
somos afortunadas la imagen que
aprendimos de nuestras madres fue más o
menos así ellas ya podían ir a la
universidad pudieron elegir qué cosa
querían estudiar y finalmente donde
querían trabajar
nosotros somos conscientes que el camino
que nos han abierto la generación de
nuestras madres ha sido anteriormente
abierto por generaciones anteriores
entonces eso hicimos decidimos estudiar
en la universidad pudimos elegir qué
cosa queríamos estudiar y luego trabajar
yo soy economista y yo soy politólogo
estudié ciencias políticas
ambas escogimos carreras de ciencias
sociales
sabemos que somos mujeres privilegiadas
por las oportunidades a las cuales hemos
tenido acceso ciertamente no es la
realidad de todas las mujeres en este
país no obstante a la medida que íbamos
creciendo nos dimos cuenta que tampoco
la teníamos tan fácil en nuestra carrera
profesional una metáfora que permite
explicar con claridad esto es la de
tubería con fugas en ciertas carreras y
en ciertas disciplinas el talento se va
jugando porque las mujeres son
discriminadas por el simple hecho de ser
mujeres quizás porque se encontraron en
el camino con un profesor que les dijo
que no eran buenas para las matemáticas
o quizás porque en este país las mujeres
ganan 30 por ciento menos que los
hombres por hacer el mismo trabajo a mí
me pasó cuando empecé a trabajar yo
ganaba bastante menos que otro chico que
hacía el mismo trabajo aquello a pesar
de que él era bachiller y yo tenía una
maestría según la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
ocde en el mundo se pierden al año 12
mil millones de dólares por no pagarle a
las mujeres lo mismo que a los hombres
cuando hacen el mismo trabajo
esta desigualdad nos estaría dando
solamente porque el talento se está
fugando sino también porque hay menos
oportunidades laborales para las mujeres
esto lo vamos a explicar a través de
otra metáfora el techo de cristal lo que
sucede con el techo de cristal es una
barrera que se le pone el desarrollo de
la carrera de las mujeres que ya no
pueden avanzar más vamos a poner un
ejemplo imaginémonos una universidad
tenemos una profesora súper capa súper
inteligente que comienza a avanzar y
asumen nuevos puestos asumen nuevas
responsabilidades pasan los años y hay
un concurso para poder acceder a ser el
nuevo decano o decana ella postula tiene
las mejores competencias sin embargo un
hombre es elegido eso es un techo de
cristal como las mismas instituciones
ponen barreras al desarrollo de la
carrera de las mujeres por ser mujeres
de hecho hace poco el grupo sophia
reveló en un estudio que a pesar de
tener variedad en las aulas
universitarias de este país es decir el
mismo número de hombres y mujeres los
altos cargos de estas instituciones
académicas siguen siendo mantenidas en
mayoría por hombre
según el mismo estudio de grupo sophia
esta desigualdad se explica por dos
grandes razones la primera es la
división sexual del trabajo en promedio
las mujeres dedican 25 horas más a la
semana que los hombres a tareas
domésticas esto impide que puedan
invertir más tiempo en el desarrollo de
un trabajo profesional otra gran razón
son estos mecanismos sutiles de
discriminación hacia lo que las mujeres
deben o no deben ser estos estereotipos
que tenemos sobre las las mujeres y los
cargos que ocupan cuando son más altos
peor
por ejemplo imaginémonos un jefe hombre
que habla muy fuerte
normalmente se dirá de él es un jefe
líder exigente pero cuando tenemos una
mujer que es jefa y habla fuerte no
hemos escuchado es una mandona es
antipática otro mecanismo que tenemos es
el de a el autosabotaje
muchas veces subestimamos lo que sabemos
cuántas veces antes de postular a un
nuevo puesto de trabajo hemos pensado
que no estamos suficientemente
capacitadas o cuando nos invitan a un
conversatorio o un panel y nos
preguntamos
tengo nada nuevo que decir pero te están
invitando incluso para esta misma charla
fue muy difícil para nosotras aceptar
nuestros logros para poder compartirlos
con ustedes así es y esto está
provocando que la voz de las mujeres no
sea escuchada y no esté ahí donde tiene
que estar según una investigación de uño
porque creo que está por ahí en el
público uno de cada cinco expertos en
medios es mujer es decir es como si yo
te dijera que cuando una productora
llama a una mujer para que asista un
programa de televisión
llama a cuatro hombres y eso eso no es
ajeno a la realidad de las ciencias
sociales pero porque nos importa que las
mujeres de las ciencias sociales hablen
en los medios porque están hablando de
problemáticas que nos afectan a nosotras
las mujeres en ciencia política decimos
que el estado es el reflejo de la
sociedad pero que el reflejo estamos
hablando si el estado no traduce en
acciones concretas problemas vinculados
a las mujeres esto se sostiene en un
conjunto de ideas preconcebidas sobre
cuál es el rol de la mujer en la
sociedad
podríamos decir que esto es una especie
de laberinto de desigualdad para poder
salir de este laberinto necesitamos
mirar hacia afuera encontrar mujeres
espejo que nos digan si si se puede
hacer el panorama es difícil para
nosotras las mujeres de ciencias
sociales ya sea porque no podemos
hacernos cargo en nuestra carrera de la
misma manera que lo hacen nuestros pares
hombres o ya sea porque no hay tantas
oportunidades conscientes de esta
problemática fue que en el 2016 un grupo
de conocidas que habían sido formadas en
ciencias sociales decidimos juntarnos
hartas de esta situación estábamos a
puertas de tomar una decisión muy
importante y vamos a elegir al próximo
presidente un presidenta de nuestro país
sin embargo nos encontrábamos con más de
lo mismo
aprendíamos la televisión y veíamos puro
hombre hablando era como si la opinión
de los hombres era la única que
importará sobre cómo iba a ir nuestro
país era como si no fuéramos realmente
la mitad
y nosotras nos encontramos que habíamos
estudiado sobre el tema estábamos
investigando sobre eso pero no teníamos
cómo aportar además nos dimos cuenta que
además de ser discriminadas por ser
mujeres había un segundo factor el hecho
de ser joven decidimos hacer algo al
respecto y en este primer paso tuvimos
el apoyo de idea internacional nos
convencimos mutuamente que era necesario
que hubieran más mujeres espejo y esto
por dos razones la primera porque era
necesario que ciertas problemáticas que
no se veían normalmente reflejadas sean
reflejadas que veamos a mujeres hablando
de temas que conocían y lo segundo
porque era necesario que ese reflejo
vuelva a quien estaba siendo reflejado
me explico era necesario que nosotras
mismas viéramos a otras mujeres hablando
de temas sobre los cuales sabían era muy
importante para nosotras incluir a otras
mujeres en la conversación para así
promover ideas de igualdad porque
debemos tener claro que lo más
importante es que hombres y mujeres
tengan acceso a las mismas oportunidades
y así fue que nació nuestro proyecto al
cual llamamos plataforma comadres
entonces lo que pensamos que lo primero
que teníamos que hacer era sentarnos en
la mesa nos dimos cuenta que no
solamente no nos estaban llamando sino
que nos decían que no habían mujeres
especialistas sobre los temas que
estaban buscando fue así que decidimos
hacer un directorio un directorio que
fuera una herramienta que permitiera
involucrar a más mujeres expertas en sus
temas y poder colocar ese conocimiento
con los que buscaban ese conocimiento ya
sean periodistas académicos o
productores de acuerdo si sabes que una
conocida revista de investigación estaba
por publicar un número sobre un tema en
el cual nosotras sabíamos que había más
mujeres jóvenes investigando recuerdos
cuántos artículos publicados por mujeres
había ninguno entonces decidimos hacer
activismo en redes sociales nos
inventamos un servicio que buscara a más
mujeres jóvenes profesionales porque tú
no eras capaz de encontrarlas y entonces
fue así que la siguiente publicación de
la revista mandamos una lista de 10
mujeres jóvenes de las cuales 2 fueron
publicadas porque para nosotras es bien
importante que nuestro rol de mujeres
espejos
los hombres vean esas acciones
reflejadas con las cuales nos
discriminan porque eso es embarazoso y
así trabajamos mujer por mujer idea por
idea luego de que nos habían invitado y
estábamos sentadas en la mesa sucedía
algo qué vergüenza hablar cada vez que
le pedíamos a una mujer que intervenga o
que escriba nos respondían un derroche
eso lo sabemos porque tenemos una
columna semanal en noticia hacer punto p
un portal web de noticias nacionales y
regionales cada semana una mujer joven
puede escribir una columna opinión sobre
ese tema que conoce pero sabemos que
expresar nuestra opinión en público no
es fácil por eso nos hemos propuesto
acompañar a esas mujeres a difundir su
saber luego de en estos casi tres años
hemos logrado publicar 100 columnas un
parto no definitivamente un parto y este
acto de escribir que parece a veces tan
sencillo es un gran paso hacia la
construcción de la confianza de estas
mujeres que están empezando su carrera
profesional la hoy si contamos la
historia del país
país una historia de cómo una columna
puede impactar en una trayectoria
nuestra comadre país escribió su primera
columna con nosotras hace un año luego
amplió esta investigación y pudo
presentarla en el coloquio de
estudiantes de ciencia política de lima
un año después país ha logrado con ese
mismo artículo ser publicada en una
revista del instituto de estudios
peruanos uno de los centros de
investigación más importantes del país
historias como ésta nos motivan a seguir
trabajando pero también nos obligan a
diseñar nuevas maneras de combatir la
desigualdad en el camino nos dimos
cuenta que para ser mujer espejo había
que aprender a hacerlo y así fue como
nace con madres juniors un programa que
busca acompañar a jóvenes universitarias
en su transición entre la vida
universitaria y el mundo laboral las
comadres juniors han hecho como las
comadres han escrito artículos han
conseguido prácticas profesionales
gracias a la plataforma pero además
tienen un espacio donde hacer catarsis
cada vez que sea necesario
yo soy profesora de ciencias políticas
siete años y me hago cuenta que mis
alumnas mujeres les cuesta mucho más
tomar la palabra que mis alumnos hombres
entonces fue ahí que se hizo evidente
para nosotras que teníamos que acompañar
otro tránsito el de los últimos años de
colegio y así fue como empezamos a
trabajar con escolares
en un taller que hicimos con candidatas
escolares a perdón a alcaldesas
escolares de vida el salvador les
pedimos que dibujen que se les hacía
difícil en su salón de clases y
dibujaron esto
un hombre comiéndose a una mujer no
dejando el hablar lo que era difícil era
tomar la palabra en público
es así que nos dimos cuenta que la
tubería con fugas sucedía porque desde
niñas no se nos estaba dando la palabra
en este taller los invitamos a dibujar
sus miedos y luego hacer un desfile de
esos miedos miedos a las cucarachas al
rechazo a los zombies y al fracaso y
aprovechamos luego de este desfile
hicimos un espacio de conversación con
estas niñas para poder hablarles también
de la inclusión de la tolerancia y la
importancia de tenernos unas a otras
como aliadas ya que algunas fotos
hemos creado casi 10 espacios de
formación para alrededor de 300 mujeres
jóvenes porque para nosotras chismear es
nuestra manera de combatir la
desigualdad en esos espacios las mujeres
han trabajado juntas para diseñar
campañas ficticias de presidentas de
alcaldesas han escrito y han dibujado
porque para nosotros solo juntas vamos a
poder derribar el techo de cristal y
evitar las fugas en la tubería mujeres
tomando el té tomando el lonche
conversando eso es lo que somos nos
gusta chismear pero nos gusta quemar de
lo que realmente nos importa de lo que
investigamos de lo que sabemos cómo nos
podemos ayudar a que nuestra voz llegue
a esos lugares donde deben estar
creemos que vernos reflejadas en el
espejo de otra mujer es un acto de
rebeldía porque en este país estamos
rodeados de héroes masculinos y creemos
que es hora que la historia también esté
contada por nosotras para nosotras cada
idea de mujer es una posibilidad de
transformar la historia y de transformar
el país ese país en donde nuestras
madres soñaron que sus hijas crecerían
defendiendo sus ideas que las harían
realidad porque sabían que ellas
tendrían el poder y la certeza de quién
sabe
muchas gracias muchas gracias